- Here's another one.
Can I be on your podcast?
- Rich! What? Come on.
(lofi-jazz music playing)
- Today we're gonna take some
of life's biggest questions.
We're gonna toss them in a Vitamix,
we're gonna press hyper blend,
create a metaphysical milkshake,
drink it down and nourish the soul.
My brothers for this mystical journey are
none other than Rainn Wilson.
You know, this guy stars
screens big and small.
Best known for his portrayal
of Dwight Schrute on The Office
and author, producer, TV host,
and scholar of religions, Reza Aslan.
These two have teamed
up for a podcast called,
you guessed it, metaphysical milkshake,
which you should all check out.
I've wanted to meet both
these guys since forever.
It finally happened.
Here we are and it is glorious.
So hit that subscribe button,
prepare to have your noodle bent
and enjoy my Vulcan mind
meld with Reza and Rainn.
Super nice to meet you guys.
I've been wanting to meet
both of you for a long time,
and it means a lot that
you would come out here
and do this in person with me.
I love the new podcast.
It's super cool.
We're gonna get into all of it.
We're gonna talk about
the questions that really matter.
But first, before we
do that, I have to say.
Rainn, I loved you on The Choe Show.
I'm obsessed with The Choe Show.
All things David Choe.
I loved how you unboxed
the painting the other day.
And I'm trying to get David on the show.
Like I just...
There's something about that guy.
It's so magnetizing.
His earnestness and his childlike nature
that I just feel like I want
to have that guy in my life-
- I'm gonna hug this out-
- How did you become friends?
- Oh, Joe and I became
friends through mutual...
Through mutual friends and met.
And then this guy I was
hosting this kind of retreat,
this like men's weekend retreat in Hawaii.
And then we hung out for a
whole weekend in Hawaii and went
snorkeling and exploring and sharing.
And he kind of, Choe shares
everything about his life.
- Its all on the sleeve with that guy.
Which is so refreshing.
You know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, he used to not be.
He used to be the opposite of that.
So he used to be jaded and
cynical and withholding
and too cool for school.
And that the crazy guy who
spent months in a Japanese prison,
and now he's on this
journey of self discovery
and it's really raw.
And I really appreciate what he does.
And yeah, he's become a good friend
and plus admire his incredible heart.
I mean, his artistry is astonishing.
- Yeah, I know.
I hope they get a second season of that.
- [Rainn] Yeah. Yeah.
- Similarly, I watched
the Bourdain doc recently,
Road Runner.
Have you seen it yet?
- Not yet. No.
- And David plays a big part in that,
especially near the end.
But in thinking about that documentary
and I suspect the influence
that Anthony had like on your own life
and how you conceptualize
believer and how you
pursued those stories through that show.
I think there seems to be a
lot of similarities there.
- Yeah. Unfortunately, I never
got a chance to meet Tony,
but I mean, his specter
is at every part of CNN,
at least it used to be.
And you know, this was a time in which
I think CNN was trying to get into
the entertainment business
and they're not as much anymore. I think.
It's funny cause I think about
what they were doing during
that decade and the...
In so far as marketing and the
entertainment industry goes,
they had this very smart plan,
which was these Bourdain-like hosts.
They would get somebody
with strong opinions
and strong views and then
they would let them pursue
their expertise-
- Their passion.
- Their passion. Yes, exactly.
But then there was this tension because
they were a news outfit
and a aggressively
center news outfit.
So there was this
constant conflict between,
"Let's get people with big opinions
and big personalities
and let's empower them
to go out there and show
our viewers the world."
But also they can't say anything
newsworthy or political or
- Controversial.
- Controversial or anything.
I mean, Bourdain had a lot to say,
but he was smart enough to
say it about British politics.
(all laughing)
- He bit his tongue on American politics.
- The things this guy would
say about British politicians
would have definitely
have gotten him fired.
But I think everybody else
very clearly got the message.
And now they're just not doing it anymore.
- Times are different.
- Now they're like
forget about that whole-
- They have Stanley Tucci going
around Italy sampling pasta.
- That's what I mean.
- So its much more milk toast.
- It's all milk toast now.
I think the only person who
has survived is Kamau Bell
and I think partly,
he learned very quickly
that he should probably just keep his
political opinions to himself.
I mean, he'll make certain
comments here and there,
but nothing controversial.
- That kind of programming
isn't gonna exist at a
place like CNN anymore.
but there are a multitude of places
where you can do that kind of thing,
like Netflix or maybe Vice
or something like that.
- Used to be. Yeah.
I think that's...
That whole genre has pretty much gone
by the wayside nowadays.
It's hard to find shows like that.
Like the Bourdain, go
around the world show.
Again, Tucci. It's like
an Italian American
eating pasta in Italy.
There's nothing controversial or on edge
about it at all.
Bourdain would go to Palestine.
He would go to Iran.
- Yeah, yeah. And Haiti and
talk about income inequality.
- Aint nobody doing that.
- Yeah. He was in Beirut when
all kinds of craziness broke out there.
- It's just funny cause
they could have done,
they could've just put a wall,
like the way Fox news
pretends to do, right?
They put a wall between
everything after 8:00 PM
and everything before 8:00
PM or 7:00 PM or whatever.
- Here, this is opinion.
- And everything before 7:00 PM is news.
Anything that happens after
8:00 PM is entertainment.
It's not even an opinion, right?
It's just entertainment.
And I think that's what CNN tried to do,
but they just,
they didn't go well.
- I'm actually trying to
get a show off the ground.
We're actually in negotiations right now,
I can't really name with who.
But me going around the world.
It's called The Geography Of Bliss.
And it's about what makes
people happy around the world.
- I love that.
- So, why are people,
year after year, happier and Finland
than they are in Romania?
And it's not just income, necessarily.
What is it culturally or
what habits or practices
make people culturally have
a greater sense of wellbeing?
- I'm sure you're familiar
with Dan Buettner then.
The Blue Zones guy?
- Oh yeah. The Blue Zones show.
- You should have him on your show
because he's all about that.
And wrote a whole book about that.
He has the blue zones of longevity,
where people live the longest,
but he's also done a similar study
to identify the pockets around the world
where people are the happiest.
And what makes them happy
and it's counterintuitive.
It's not the things that we've been taught
that is shoved down our throats
through marketing and media.
- Because I was reading this
article speaking of Finland
and there's a Finnish word
that I don't remember,
but it basically is a
word that is kind of like,
essentially translates to
"Keep your expectations
relatively low and in check."
So why are they happier?
Because they're not expecting to live
a wildly outrageously happy life.
Whereas we Americans feel like,
"Life, liberty, pursuit of happiness."
And it's kind of like,
"I've got stuff, I've got cotton candy,
I've got video games, I've
got 147 apps on my phone.
Why am I not happy?
I want to be fucking
happy. Why am I not happy?"
And there's this crazed outrage
for happiness whereas this,
I'm not sure that the
Finnish way is the right way,
by the way but it was
an interesting article
that had this cultural
tempered response to life.
So then you're kind of like,
when you are happy you're
pleasantly surprised like,
"Wow, I ate some boiled fish
and I was a little bit happy.
Yay me." You know?
- As opposed to the expectation
that we're meant to be happy
all the time.
- Well I would say that-
- And then suffer disappointment.
- Baked into the concept of
the American dream, right?
Is this idea that you can
be more, you can do more,
your children will be
better off than you are.
Anyone here can rise to the
heights of wealth and power
with just hard work.
None of that is true.
None of that is true
anywhere in the world. Right?
You could work as hard as you want to.
You could do everything right.
And it's just not guaranteed
that there will be a
steady progress upward on the ladder,
but imagine living and
being born in a country
in which that's the ethos.
That there's more.
There's something else.
- That there's something
if you haven't achieved it.
So if you are not better
off than your parents,
are not better off than your grandparents
and not happy or making more
money, owning more property,
it's your fault.
- Something has gone off the rails.
With a light dusting of
entitlement on top of it.
- But the only reason that this did work
in the United States is because
we stole a ton of land from the natives
and we had slave labor to
build our infrastructure.
So yeah, from the late 1800 to the,
let's say 1970s or 1980s,
there was unchecked growth
because we weren't Finland.
We weren't an enclosed land area
just trying to subsist in a land.
We were just growing and
moving and having railroads
and having more timber and
gold and natural resources.
So we were able to kind
of sustain this growth
through that time period.
But now, of course, here we are.
Life, liberty, and the
pursuit of happiness.
And then for the last generation or two
things have been getting
worse on every level.
- Yeah. And philosophically speaking,
a lot of the problems
that we have as a country,
certainly when it comes to
this, sort of, giant chasm
in social incomes and
the huge gap between the
poor and the wealthy.
The way that we treat wealthy people,
the way that we think about
religion and spirituality
in the United States.
It's all a by-product of this
American Dream ethos, right?
We look at rich people and
assume that they are rich
because they deserved to be rich. Right?
We had this conversation a lot
when Trump was running for office, right?
It's like, "I'm rich so therefore
I know what I am doing."
We actually did a podcast episode on this,
this idea that wealth
doesn't just equal success,
it equals morality.
We look at rich people
as being more moral.
Look at the prosperity gospel,
a thing that could really only
exist in the United States.
Right?
The whole concept of which is
wealth is indicative of your salvation.
If you are rich, it's
because God has rewarded you.
It's a symbol of the
fact that you are saved.
And so you should pursue wealth
the way that you would
pursue spiritual edification.
I mean, name another country
in which that is a prevailing view of
tens of millions of the citizenship.
It's just crazy.
- Yeah. I think on top of that,
also just the mere statement,
"The pursuit of happiness" is
wrongheaded in the sense that
happiness is a byproduct
of other pursuits,
such as trying to find
purpose in your life.
Like you mentioned the Finnish word,
in Okinawa they have a word Ikigai
which is essentially means
to live a life that is purposeful.
To wake up in the morning
and feel a sense of
purpose and obligation and
happiness being a by-product of
orienting your life
around that type of ethos,
rather than the pursuit of
accumulation that has led to
you know, and this is
what I want to get into,
this crisis of consciousness
that we find ourselves.
Certainly, religion is a
predominant aspect of
living in America but
on a spiritual level,
I feel like we're bereft
of the meaning that is behind
the pursuit of a spiritual life
and that's led to so much
of our fractured society
and our inability to
communicate with each other
and the way in which we
prioritize our lives.
- We're all about that, man.
- Yeah, I know. I know, this is your jam.
This is why, a big reason why I wanted
to have you guys here.
Like I'm looking at the
people that you've selected
to have on your show.
There's an overlap with some of my guests
and I know you have some upcoming guests
that are people that I've had on my show.
And you know the...
- We basically looked
through your guest lists
and we thought, "We gotta
get that Rabbi Mordecai."
- Not that either of you
would ever have a problem
finding any of these people
but whoever you want...
Yeah. You got to have rabbi Mordecai on.
He's the best.
- He's amazing. Wow, wow.
But I'm interested in how
all of this came about.
I mean, essentially a Baha'i
actor and a Sufi Muslim
walk into a bar or a soundstage and say,
"Hey, you've dominated screens
big and small. So have I.
What are we gonna do next?"
"Well, I guess we'll do a podcast."
- Actually it was on the stage, not a bar.
- It was a stage and it was...
We met on a stage at USC
and we were doing...
I was emceeing an event about
the treatment of members
of the Baha'i faith
in its home country of Iran
and how they're being
terribly persecuted there
by the Muslim theocracy and-
- [Reza] That's an understatement.
- And Reza was a speaker
and featured speaker there.
And we met, that was
the first time we met.
And then we met at a fellow Baha'i's house
who was a producer and funder of media
and Reza had just started
his production company,
working in media and Aslan media?
No, what's it?
- BoomGen was the... yeah.
- Boom Generation.
BoomGen Studios and then he
wrote his book about Jesus.
He wrote this little book about Jesus,
became a number one bestseller
for eight months in a row
and redefined how so many
people look at the Bible.
And we did an event where I
got to do a Q and A
with him about his book.
I was a huge fan.
- Thank you for that,
by the way.
That was really nice of you.
- We were in that
little church. Yeah.
And-
- Eight years ago.
And then bumped into each other through...
And then we're having breakfast one day
and I was talking about my
spiritual journey in life
and what I'm dealing with
and Reza's talking about his
spiritual journey in life
and what he's dealing
with and his challenges.
And we found our conversations
just bouncing around
like the way they are this morning.
And we're like, "This
should be a podcast."
"We really should have
a microphone between us
and be having this conversation
with the listening audience."
And at the time this
company that I had founded,
SoulPancake, a digital media company that
probes life's biggest questions
and is all about uplifting
challenging content.
They produced it and we
did season one on Luminary,
now did season two out in
the general podcast O-sphere.
And that's kind of how it started,
but it was essentially a shared love of
exactly what you were talking about.
That there are these
huge questions about life
that have been relegated to
philosophical academics that you take
in undergrad Philosophy 101
and that people
oftentimes steer away from.
I have some stuff to
say about that later on,
specifically with a recent
death of a friend of mine.
So we just felt like there's
all these spiritual tools
and spiritual perspectives
about looking at
all of these questions.
Not that every episode
that we do is spiritual.
Some episodes, we were
just talking about politics
and sociology or just feelings,
but underneath there's an underpinnings of
a spiritual connection,
which has to do with reason
and purpose.
Why are we here?
And how does that guide our
approach to asking these
deep probing questions?
- And it's not about the
answers so much as it is
the practice of wrestling
with the questions
and the practical tools that
we can extract from them because
philosophy and spirituality
should be a roadmap
for how we live.
It shouldn't just live
in the halls of academia
or in conversations behind closed doors.
There's great practical wisdom
packed into all of this, of course.
And I think we're in a culture
that's in desperate need
of that kind of mainline injection
into how we think and
prioritize our lives.
- Yeah. Sufism has this concept that
it's all about the path
and not the destination.
The important thing is
to be moving forward,
stage after stage.
Evolving at every step.
Getting closer and closer,
but recognizing that
you'll probably never
get to the destination
and that's okay.
And it's the same kind of
philosophy that we bring to
a lot of these existential
questions, which is,
You said it right.
The question sometimes is more
important than the answer.
Now, occasionally we'll come up
with some pretty good answers.
- We did a few jackpots.
- We did a few jackpots
and surprising too.
And also-
- In fact, let me just jump in there.
- And Reza this podcast that
was two ago, Mike Schur.
- I was just gonna say. Go ahead.
- I wanna tee you up because you had...
It was really fun having a
conversation with Mike Schur,
who was a writer, director on The Office,
he's the creator of Parks and
Rec and also The Good Place.
And we were talking about
the show, The Good Place
and about being good and that
was our life's big question
of the episode.
"How do we be good?"
"How do we know what
that means to be good?"
And over the course of this conversation,
I saw this like giant, it was a cartoon,
a giant light bulb over Reza's head
as some things clicked in.
Do you wanna do you wanna...?
- So a lot of the questions that-
- Sorry, have we hijacked your podcast?
- This is great, man. I can relax.
- Can we ask you questions?
- You got your bros.
- Have a vegan donut or
something. Whatever you eat.
- A lot of the episodes that we do
are based on just questions
that Rainn and I have.
And one of, at least my biggest questions,
has been for a very, very long time,
How can you be good?
how can you just be a good person.
Divorced from religious
obligations and dogma
and all of that stuff.
And I went into this
conversation as I often do,
assuming there's no real answer to this,
but let's have fun with the question.
And Mike I think summed it up so well.
He said, "The way that you can be good
is to try."
And it was those simple little things
that sometimes happen
in the podcast, right?
The same thing happened when we talked to
the great Krista Tippett about wisdom.
What is wisdom?
Well, all right, I've got a
couple of answers for that
but none of them are...
You know, "How can you be wise?"
"I don't know."
I can wax philosophical about that.
But again she encapsulated
it so perfectly.
She said, "Wisdom is found
in the impact that you leave
on the people around you."
And I thought, "Well, that's an answer."
- Yeah, I've never heard it put that way.
- That's just an answer.
Sometimes there are answers
and sometimes those answers
hit me like a ton of bricks.
Those two have stayed with me
for a very, very long time.
But we always go into
these episodes recognizing
that at the end of this
45, 50 minute conversation,
maybe all that we've done
is really ask the question
in a proper way.
Gave it the weight that it deserves
and the weight that so often
we don't give any more.
Rainn said it perfectly.
These are the kinds of questions
that you used to ask in college.
All right, been a long time
since I've been in college,
but a very long time since
I think anyone at this table
has been in college
and now we have kids and we
have jobs and we have mortgages
and we have bills to pay.
And I don't ask those questions anymore.
They still rattle around
in the back of my brain
but they're rarely actually
things I get to think about.
And that's what we get to do
with Metaphysical Milkshake,
is think about them and
hell we get paid to do it.
- A little bit.
- I mean, a little bit, but still.
- It's not very much.
Not The Office, sort of, network TV
in its ninth season? Nah.
- I think you need to
recalibrate your barometer.
(all laughing)
A little bit, Rainn.
- What Reza said, he's an
academic and an author.
He's a professor at the UC
system so he's fine. You know?
- Are you still teaching now?
You teach creative writing, yeah?
- I do. I do.
I'm a professor of creative
writing at UC Riverside.
I've been there since, I guess, 2007.
- We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and
I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really
enjoy my latest book,
Voicing Change.
Featuring excerpts from,
poignant essays by,
and glorious photography of
some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus
years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous, artful
compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in.
All wrapped in a hardcover
coffee table form
that provides a great
taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a
beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively
available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
Well, I thought what would be fun
since this is all about
questions big and small,
is to do something a little bit different.
This is an idea that I got from Rob Bell.
You guys know Rob Bell right?
(Rainn and Reza agreeing)
Rob Bell, I'm certain,
has gone on your show.
- He's been on. He did a two-parter.
- The only two parter ever.
You can't get him to be quiet.
- No, no, no. Yeah.
- You don't want him to be quiet.
- You don't want them to be quiet. Yeah.
- But I went to...
He did a live podcast at
Largo with Liz Gilbert,
and they did a choose your adventure thing
with what we have here in front of us,
which is essentially a fishbowl with
much of wadded up pieces of
paper on each piece of paper.
On each piece of paper here
I put one of these big questions.
So I thought we could just pick one out.
This could go terribly wrong, by the way,
this could be as awful as (indistinct).
and have the dorm room conversation.
- Lets do it. Lets pretend-
- [Rainn] Pretend we're in conversation.
- Lets pretend were freshmen.
First time away from out parents.
- And if we've already
talked about it or it's bad,
we could just go back to the well.
- What you got there?
- There's some stupid ones in there too.
- Does everybody have a purpose?
- [Rich] That's a good one.
- [Rainn] I think that's a great one.
- Let's do that one. Let's do that one.
- I believe that everyone has a purpose.
I believe this with all of my heart
and in a very strong way because
as a member of the Baha'i faith
but not just the Baha'i faith,
I think anyone who has...
I mean, I think that's an
answer that applies to both
theists and atheists,
but as a member of the
Bahai faith, I believe that
we are on an eternal spiritual journey.
That this, you know, our soul,
our eternal part of ourselves
is encased in this flesh
tuxedo for 80 or 90 years.
We slough it off and
we continue our journey
beyond time and space.
So while we're here,
everyone has a purpose.
Now it may not be everyone
on planet earth has a purpose
like Oprah has a purpose.
- We can't all be Oprahs.
- We can't have 7 billion
Oprah's on the planet.
But I do think that
this is one of the really exciting tasks
is there's there's a question wrapped,
there's a riddle wrapped
inside this question,
which is our purpose
is to find our purpose.
And as soon as we found our purpose,
we have to be not sure
that that's our purpose
and we have to keep finding our purpose.
So by the time we're 97 and we keel over,
hopefully we're all
continuously on this...
At the very beginning footsteps
of this eternal journey
toward finding what that purpose is
and it may shift and change.
And so whether you call that God
or The Great Spirit or just
the power of the universe
or the winds of the cosmos
or the mystic connection
or whatever you want to call God,
which has become a four letter word
and is a tough concept to dig into,
but the winds, the holy spirit,
the winds of the cosmic
power of the creative force
that surrounds us, that's
within us, without us,
beyond us, beyond limitations
and time and space.
These winds have a very special...
We have a very special
relationship with them, I believe.
And it's for...
It's like when you go sailing,
I don't know anything about sailing.
I've been sailing like twice,
but the whole idea that
you tack your sails to try
and get the most out of
the wind depending on,
you have a vague, you know,
"I want to go toward that island,"
but you may not go directly to the island.
The winds may take you off
to the left a little bit,
and then back, or you may have to zigzag.
The wind stall for a little
bit. You turn on your motor.
Then the winds are
pushing you right there,
but you are trying to align
yourself with those winds.
And it's really, it's exciting.
I think it's a really
exciting part of being alive.
Maybe the most exciting
part of being alive.
And this is where I think
that young people, especially,
I don't know about older people.
I mean, older people,
we get set in our ways
and like Reza said, we've got
kids and jobs and mortgages,
and we have a little bit
of stuff figured out.
But especially for this
mental health crisis
that is afflicting kids under 20 or 30,
it's astonishingly insidious
and toxic and fatal.
But this connection to this question
is a big part of
helping to use a spiritual
tool to solve that issue,
solve that problem.
- Beautifully put.
- Hard agree.
Thanks. Can we just end the podcast there?
- yeah boom.
- The only thing that
I'll just say to people
who are listening to this,
because I could listen to that all day.
It's a hundred percent true.
I agree with it a hundred percent
and I have like philosophical
and theological reasons why
I agree with it
and experiential reasons
what I agree with it.
But what I'll just say is that
if you are listening to this and saying,
"Okay, fine. Everybody has a purpose.
Will then, you know, how do I...
Am I doing my purpose?
How do I know what my purpose is?"
If you don't know, then
you're not doing it.
For those people...
I feel like I am achieving my purpose.
I would say probably you
too, Rich. Yeah, Rainn.
I mean, you're doing what your purpose is.
- I wrestle with it.
Truth be told. but yes,
by and large, I do.
- [Reza] Well, I mean-
- It's a constant, for me
a constant a series of the,
we use going back to
the sailboat metaphor,
adjusting those sails.
- That metaphor is so perfect
because everyone who has had
this experience will tell you
that when the wind is
right and your sail is
exactly where it's supposed to be,
and you're moving smoothly.
And I mean this metaphorically
not actually on the water,
but I mean in life, you
know it. You know it.
And you always know when
you're fighting the wind.
So pay attention to that feeling.
Pay attention that. If you
sitting there thinking yourself,
"Well, then how do I
know what my purpose is?"
Are you fighting the wind?
Is that what it feels like?
Then you're not pursuing your purpose.
- And here's another thing I'll say.
You ready for this?
- I'm ready. The bar is high now.
- Okay.
(Reza laughs)
Fasten your podcast seat belts, Rich.
If people are listening
to this and saying,
"Well, I just don't know.
I can't find mine and I've
tried to be a massage therapist
and then I had a job as this,
and I tried to start up a business here
and I went back to school for this,
and it's not working out and wah, wah."
Well, I will say,
and this is gonna sound crazy.
It's gonna sound crazy. Pray.
Pray. That doesn't mean
you have to go into
a Catholic church and cross yourself
and look at an icon to pray.
It doesn't mean that there's
an old white man with a beard
on a cloud granting wishes
like Santa Claus from up above.
But we live in a society, in LA at least,
and I find this really interesting that
everyone in LA, not everyone,
a lot of people in LA
meditate but don't pray
Because "I have such a hard
time with the higher power"
and everyone in mid America
prays and doesn't meditate.
So they don't deeply contemplate,
or they're not open to
receiving the wisdom
from the universe, from the act of prayer.
But people in LA are just
receiving and never asking,
because another reason why,
because it takes humility to pray
and people in LA, on the coast,
don't have a lot of humility.
It's in short supply.
When you pray, and again,
I'm just talking about opening
your heart to the spirit
of the cosmic creative
force of the universe.
I'm not talking about-
- Crossing yourself in a...
- "Oh God, please give me a pony.
It's just saying, "Universe,
where would you have me go?"
"All loving Providence that surrounds me,
what would you have me do and
how would you have me do it?
I'm open to signs."
Just be like, "I'm open."
You can just wake up and
you just say, "I'm open"
and that's a prayer.
- Yeah. There's an expansiveness to
broadening your perception and
your willingness to just
be in that receiving mode
and in the asking mode.
But I think we all, to some extent,
have this yearning inside of us.
For some, they're very conscious of it,
for others, perhaps it's
a little bit more muted,
but this sense of there is
something for me out there.
And I do think there's
beauty in pursuing that,
but I think you're right, Reza,
most people don't know
what their purpose is.
Perhaps they don't spend enough time
or very much time at
all thinking about it.
But I do believe that it
is out there for everybody.
And I think that part
of the beauty of life
is the pursuit of finding that.
And I would tweak a little
bit Rainn what you said,
this idea that once you find it
then you continue to find it.
Like you iterate on it or you
remain open to it changing
or morphing in certain ways.
But I think an important
piece also to that is
then sharing what you learned
in service to other people.
The service piece of it I think really
strengthens that sense of purpose
and the search for it is,
yes, prayer, meditation and all of that
but ultimately it is an inside job.
You have to become
integrated with who you are.
You have to get to know
yourself, like know thyself,
because otherwise you're not
gonna hear that vibration
and your boat is gonna be
tacking against the wind.
And it's only when you
know yourself well enough
that you can determine, "Okay,
I have to course correct
and here's how I get more in
alignment with like, my energy
and paying attention
to the way the universe
responds to that."
So you can make those
fine tuned adjustments
that lead you in that
direction that you seek.
- I mean, I'll use myself as an example.
Classic LA narcissist.
- A Praying narcissists.
(Rainn laughs)
- He prays to himself. He
should have mentioned that part.
- To my bobble head.
(Reza and Rich laughing)
For most of my life, my
purpose was to be an actor.
That's all I wanted to do.
I just wanted to learn how to act.
I wanted to be a better and better actor.
I wanted to learn skills of acting.
Then I wanted to learn how
to act in front of a camera
and I wanted to do comedy and drama
and play different kinds of roles
and play serial killers
and weirdos and slapstick
and you name it.
And my whole life from
when I was a teenager
and I first started acting at 16,
all the way up well into my
forties and late forties,
I lived, slept and breathed acting.
And I saw myself as actor, as storyteller.
I didn't just say it like,
"Oh, I just want a job
so I can buy a house."
Although that was nice.
But you know, as an actor
in the greatest sense
you're part of telling
a story and entertaining
and there is a service component to it.
And then it's been very interesting for me
because over the last
six, eight years or so,
it's held much less, kind of,
of a draw.
I still like doing it sometimes, but
my life isn't based around
that next acting job.
So it has been like, "Is
this a change in purpose?
A shift in purpose in my life.?
So starting SoulPancake,
writing more stuff,
writing books, working
with Reza like on this pod
and doing more service
work, nonprofit work
that I do with my wife
in Haiti, et cetera.
Finding more meaning from that stuff
cause purposes can change.
- Yeah. That's interesting.
I mean, you're a G in the
whole digital content space.
I mean, SoulPancake was 2009.
When did you start that?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean, pretty early
in the whole high-vibe,
sharing, cool content.
- We were the first.
- Taking wisdom and making
it cool for young people.
Creating digestible content.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was an amazing adventure to
start that with some friends
and to just be ideating on like,
speaking of that service component,
what can we do for young
people on the internet
that's cool and fun and
that can be a business?
That can be a sustainable
business model, as well.
- Wasn't Metaphysical
Milkshake in the back of a van
or something, or did you
have a different name then?
You were kind of doing-
- We used to drive around
in a van and asked people to
get in and talk about existential issue.
- [Rich] Steve-O's doing that now.
(all laugh)
- The, I guess....
Metaphysical Milkshake was the
original name of SoulPancake.
The very first name.
but we quickly scrapped
that because it was so weird
and it became,
yeah, it was a talk show
in the back of my van.
But it was about life's big questions,
but I would interview
actors and celebrities
and stuff like that.
So we just kind of held onto the name.
I love the name and moved
it into the podcast space.
- Reza, you were about to say something.
- Just to put a close to the
conversation about purpose.
Yeah, I really like what Rainn was saying.
My wife and I have a
couple of life mottoes,
family mottoes that we focus on a lot
and one of them is have
a mission, not a job.
And I say this to my
students all the time.
Cause I think so many of us pursue jobs.
"I want to be an actor.
That's what my passion is."
"I want to be a writer.
That's where my passion is."
That's great.
But what's your mission?
Your mission is bigger than
the things that you do, right.
If you have a mission then
you can have multiple ways
in which that mission expresses itself
like acting or writing or service
or whatever the thing is.
So if you're sitting there and
you're thinking to yourself,
"What do I want to do with my life?"
Tweak that question just a little bit.
What is your mission in life?
Pursue that mission and I promise you,
- [Rainn] Doors will open.
- People will pay you for it.
- But it's the rare individual who
has a grip on that, right?
I feel like, especially with young people,
you have to live some life.
You have to travel, you
have to collect experiences,
You have to put yourself out there.
How could you possibly...
It's not a Thunderbolt.
I mean, there's always the
kid who at age six knows
what he or she wants to do,
but that's really the outlier.
- Well, this is what I
always say to, when I,
cause I do some speaking at
college campuses and stuff too,
and I just tell people,
"Twenties are a waste of time."
Don't even worry about it.
Don't try and get it figured out.
The point of your twenties
is to try 12 different things
and fail at nine of them
so that you can come out.
But there's all this
societal pressure of like...
That's not urination by the way.
If you're hearing that in a microphone,
that's Reza pouring a glass of water.
- There's no proof of that.
- But truthfully in society right now,
you talk to so many college kids
and they're so depressed
at 2021 cause they don't...
They haven't gotten the perfect
internship over the summer
and they're not pre-enrolled
in the perfect grad program
and they don't have their job aligned.
Now I know it's hard to
make a living out there.
It's hard to have a
career and make a living.
It's much harder than in
the eighties and nineties
when we were getting our educations
but nonetheless, if you view the twenties
as a workshop stage,
then it gives you some, so
you can relax a little bit,
- But you gotta do some
counter-programming around that.
You're asking young people
to step off the hamster wheel
and that's pretty scary,
especially for a kid
who's been on that track where it's like,
"Get into the right
college, get the right job"
And then, "Oh, if I opt out of that
then life's gonna pass me by."
But obviously it's quite the contrary.
- And I think too for mission,
and we've been on this
topic too long, but-
- Yeah, we're gonna have
to pick another thing.
Here you go, Reza. I just
think in terms of mission too,
It doesn't have to be grand.
We don't have to change the world.
Your mission can be,
"I want to build beautiful
things out of wood
and I want to have a nice family."
- That's exactly what I
mean. That's what I mean.
I don't mean like, yes,
maybe your mission is to
change the world. Great.
Okay. Well done Greta.
My mission from a very early age was to
change the way that people
think through stories.
I didn't say to myself,
"I'm wanna be a writer."
I'm gonna be television producer.
I'm gonna be a podcast host,"
but all of those are just
different ways of telling stories
to change the way that people think.
So those are the jobs that I do,
but the mission is something else.
- [Rainn] That's great.
- All right. My turn, My turn, My turn.
Here we go. Here we go. All right.
What do we got here? Okay.
Oh, He he he. This is right up my alley.
What do people misunderstand
about spirituality?
- Ooh, that's a good one.
- We're not gonna get past
this question, are we?
- We just spend the next four
hours talking about this.
- This is it right here. All right.
Rainn and I have a lot to say about this.
Let me start.
First of all,
that religion and faith
are two different things.
They're not the same thing.
I think in a lot of thinking,
people just assume that
that they're the same.
In fact, the way that they talk, right?
They'll say things like, "I
believe in Christianity" or
"I believe in the Bible."
And I'm like, "You believe it exists?"
I don't understand what you mean by that
because these are not ends
in themselves,
their paths to an end.
Religion, spirituality,
whatever that means.
Faith, whatever that means.
It's individualistic, it's
nebulous, it's ineffable,
it's undefinable, it's mysterious.
It's experiential more than anything else.
It's about how you see yourself
and your place in the universe.
Religion is the language that you use
to express that feeling. Right?
We have ways of talking about
so many of our emotions.
We have an entire language
dedicated to expressing love.
dedicated to expressing anger.
What is the language to express
this mysterious, ineffable
part of human nature?
Well, it's religion and that's all it is.
And the problem that I think
so many people get into
is that they forget that their religion,
whatever their religion,
is a means to an end.
They confuse it for the
end, in and of itself.
And so, I think that's the biggest,
to me, that's the biggest problem.
So when people talk about spirituality,
especially people who
claim to not be spiritual.
What they really mean
is I'm not religious.
That's what they really mean.
When you start to poke
at them and ask and probe
and try to figure out what
do they mean when they say,
"I don't believe in God or
I don't accept religion."
What are they actually talking about?
You start to recognize that.
Yeah, they're not talking
about spirituality.
They're not talking about faith.
They're talking about rules
and rituals and belief systems
and dogmas and do's and don'ts
and institutions and authority structures.
What does any of that to do
with faith and with spirituality?
So that's, I would say, the first thing.
The first thing is
recognizing the difference
between those two things.
- Well said, and I
agree a hundred percent.
And so many people can't
differentiate the two.
I remember I was doing this
movie with this director
and he's like, "Oh, so
you're all into spirituality
and God and stuff."
And we were touring this
old church at the time.
I was like, "Yeah, I believe in God
and I love reading about
it and studying about it
and talking about it and stuff."
He's like, "Oh, I don't believe in God."
And I was like, "Oh really? You don't."
He was like, "Oh no, my
parents dragged me to church
every day, not even once a
week, I had to go every day
and sit for mass and I had to do this
and they made me a choir boy.
Oh, I don't believe in God."
So it had been completely fused with his
traumatic childhood experience.
The fact that, you know,
is there a creative force in the universe
that transcends the material,
has been kind of locked in,
zipped in with that childhood experience.
But I think that two
things come to mind for me.
What do people misunderstand
about spirituality?
One is that
in the Hindu concept of Maya or illusion,
it's that not only is it
that the material world
is an illusory world.
It's not even that so much,
people misunderstand that,
from my limited understanding
in reading about it,
but this concept of Maya is that there is,
we are fooled into thinking
that there is duality.
So it's not that we're
fooled by the material,
we're fooled into thinking
that there was duality.
So I would say that
this constant battle of
like religion versus science
or spirituality versus science,
that they're the same thing.
There is one reality.
There's two ways of kind
of measuring, quantifying,
looking at, interacting with this reality.
Science is an incredible
way of repeating experiments
and understanding the material world
and spirituality is again,
it's the science of
understanding the other aspects
of being alive.
About love and service and kindness
and our journeys and mission,
And that they're both are harmonious.
There is not a false duality.
There's not a Maya,
there's not an illusion of
this versus that.
We're very mind, body, spirit. Yeah.
- I was going to say that
the way that I refer to it,
there are two modes of knowing.
There are two modes of knowing.
That's what they are.
- Yeah, that's perfectly said.
I think the other thing that people
misunderstand about spirituality is,
I really like nuts and bolts
practical spirituality.
I don't think the spirituality has to be
really airy fairy.
It doesn't have to be
really like this nebulous
feeling of connectivity,
although that's nice.
There's nothing wrong with that.
There are spiritual tools that
can make our lives better,
that can actually make us
happier and more fulfilled.
So there are...
And those are found in
all the faith traditions.
They're found in Christianity,
Judaism, Buddhism-
- So that's a corner stone of Baha'i.
This idea that there's a
universality of all these
strains of faith.
- Yeah. So the Baha'is believe that
all of the world's religions
come from the same source
and this God has chosen
to educate humanity
by sending down these divine
teachers throughout time.
We know many of them.
Zorro, Aster, Abraham.
To go way back, Krishna.
But the Buddha, Jesus,
Muhammad, and now Baháʼu'lláh
is the most recent of
these divine teachers.
And they all, it's like
they're teachers in a school,
the school has a purpose, which
is to educate its students.
But you go have to go through kindergarten
and then first grade, third grade...
The teachers all know the same amount.
They're all just as...
What? Professional or just as wise.
They have the same amount of knowing,
but they're just slowly unfolding
this spiritual maturation
of the human species so that
these spiritual tools can
be found throughout history.
And they are there to
make our lives better,
Both personally and also societally.
- [Rich] Yeah.
- I was just gonna, just
add one more thing to this
and excuse me, I'm just gonna
get a little academic here
because I think it's important.
What we call religion
we could probably trace maybe
6, 7, 8, 9,000 years,
what we refer to as
institutionalized religion.
What I mean by that is,
it's a cohesive system
of beliefs and practices.
It's a top-down system.
It's institutionalized.
There's a priesthood or
whatever the case may be.
- Books with rules and teachings.
- Yeah. Well, even before
there was any writing.
So writing was invented, maybe 3000 BC
and what we call religion,
we can go maybe to like 10,000, 12,000 BC.
So that's the oldest temple that we have
is around that period.
Between 12 and 10,000 BC,
the oldest temple that we have found.
What we call spirituality,
and I think Rainn hit it
on the head when he said
what we mean by spirituality,
which is recognition and communion with
the thing that is beyond
the material realm.
So this urge for transcendence,
that which is beyond.
We have hard archeological evidence
for the belief
in the non-material world
that goes back 200, 300,000 years.
We have material evidence of that belief
in Neanderthals.
- Not even the human species.
- Not even in homo sapiens, exactly.
We can trace that belief
to a hundred thousand years
before there was such a
thing as homo sapiens.
And then I would say even further,
there's some material evidence
that's a little bit more debatable
that goes back all the way to Cro-Magnon.
Over the last 30, 40 years or so,
there's been this kind of new science
in the study of religion
and it's called the
Cognitive Theory of Religion.
A lot of these great cognitive theorist
is people who study the
way that the brain works
have started to ask themselves,
"Why is spirituality,"
or the religious impulse
as I like to call it,
"why is that a universal phenomenon?"
Why is it something that
exists in every culture,
in every people, in
every part of the world
for all of time?
Why is it something that
predates our species? Why?
Because if it predates our species,
if it's universal then there must be some
evolutionary reason for it, right?
There's gotta be some kind
of adaptive advantage to it.
Long story short, there is
no adaptive advantage to it.
We've asked every question
that we could possibly ask.
"Well, maybe it's about
morality." "No, that's not it."
"Maybe it's about answering
questions." "That's not it."
"Maybe it's about social
cohesion." "Nope, that's not it."
We've answered all of those questions
and the fact of the matter
is that we don't know.
We have no idea why, what
we call spirituality,
is a universal phenomenon.
Part of our evolution as a species.
What is the purpose of it? We don't know.
But the best answer that
the cognitive scientists
that I look to, the best answer
that they've given is that
it's an accident.
It's just a by-product of
some other adaptive advantage
that was necessary very
early in our evolution.
Something that helped us survive
and as a accidental echo of that thing
came the universal
conception of spirituality.
That's a good effort.
- It's super interesting.
I would suspect that part of,
would it not be considered
an evolutionary advantage
to, part of this being this
quest to understand things
that we don't understand, right?
We look up to the stars.
We don't have the scientific
tools or the acumen to really
understand what that is. We create myths.
We create stories around that,
that help us feel better about who we are,
feel like our lives have
some level of meaning.
And in modern times God is dead.
Spirituality, religion has
been supplanted by science.
Science has become our God.
Science is what we look to
for all of these answers.
And there's a hubris
within the human being that
science will ultimately, if
we keep doubling down on it,
provide everything that we need,
which now makes spirituality and religion
an antiquated idea altogether.
And yet it prevails.
- That was one of the first theories about
why the universal phenomenon
of the religious impulse.
The problem with that theory
is that there's literally
no adaptive advantage, whatsoever,
to having airy fairy answers
to the questions of the universe.
Quite the contrary.
In fact, what those answers do,
"Why does the sun shine?"
"Because there's a sun
God," et cetera. All that.
What those answers end up doing
is forcing individuals to
exert resources and energy
that should be spent on survival.
So it's actually the opposite
of an adaptive advantage.
- Because if you're
burying your Viking king
and you put your swords
and jewelry in the tomb
because he's gonna need them to go
on his quest into Valhalla,
then you've done a great
disservice to your community.
- Absolutely. I mean,
we don't need to get too
deeply involved in this,
but I mean, I'm sure a lot
of people out there are like,
"Well, what about this
and what about that?"
"What about social cohesion?"
"Doesn't religious belief or spirituality
help a community become tighter?
And so if a community is tighter
they have a better chance of survival?"
True, except that that's
not how Neanderthals
or homo sapiens created community.
Community was kinship.
You didn't create your community
because you all believe the same thing.
You created your community because you
shared the same blood.
- Honestly, that didn't really
happen until Christianity.
- Or your survival depends on it.
- But here's the bottom line
of what I'm trying to say
here is that we don't know.
Maybe we'll find out one day.
We don't know why religion, or I'm sorry,
why the religious impulse,
the desire for transcendence,
the belief that there is something else
besides the material realm,
why is that universal?
Why is it part of our evolutionary
process? We don't know.
But embedded in the question, to me,
is the answer.
Embedded in the question is the fact that
whatever spirituality is, okay,
back to the question,
what do we misunderstand
about spirituality?
Whatever it is,
it is the normal
functioning of your brain.
That's what it is.
Your brain is designed to think
that there is a reality
beyond the material realm.
- And we've been thinking this
way for a 100, 200,000 years.
- Yes. So you can deny
that if you want to.
You can say, "No, there isn't anything
beyond the material realm." Fine.
But that's a conscious decision.
Your brain is designed
to think that there is.
And maybe we should take
that seriously for a minute.
Yeah, We can talk about
why. We don't know.
But the fact that it does,
the fact that your brain
is meant to think this way,
should make us stop and think,
"Well, maybe there's something to it."
- It's Fantastic. I thought
you said you were tired today.
- [Rich] Yeah. I know. You
said you were out of it.
- Then somebody brought up spirituality.
(all chatter)
- Before you do that, though, I wanted to
follow up on one point
that you made Rainn about
dualistic thinking.
Reza you said many people will say,
"I'm not spiritual" because
they're affiliating that
with religion.
I think in Los Angeles, it's the inverse.
People will say they're spiritual
but they're not religious.
But on that idea of binary thinking that
science is at the
exclusion of spirituality.
I mean, for me,
the more you delve into spirituality,
the more amazing everything becomes
and the deeper you dive into science,
the more mystical it becomes.
I don't see those as being
mutually exclusive pursuits.
You can be rational and science minded
and insist on evidence for your beliefs
and be profoundly, deeply spiritual.
- Yeah. Rainn and I, We were just,
we actually just were talking about this
on a recent episode.
The foundation of...
Let me put it this way.
The fundamental law of physics is
the preservation of energy and matter.
The belief that everything
that exists today
has always existed and will always exist
as long as the universe exists.
Man, Sufi's have been saying that
for 1500 years.
You're right. The more we
know about the universe,
the more science advances,
the more spiritual it starts to sound.
You're absolutely right.
- All right. Let's see what we got here.
- See what you got.
- I'm gonna pick the dud.
(Reza laugh)
- See that self-defeating
attitude right there,
What's up with that?
- Oh, well. I didn't pick a dud,
but I picked what we just talked about.
"What is faith and how does
it differ from religion?"
And we already traversed
that a little bit so
let's go on to something else.
"Can you be rational science
and still spiritual?"
We covered that.
- Okay.
- Yeah we pretty good at this.
You know what, we can
just ask the question
and splice it in the answers.
- Let's see.
How do you be a good person?
- Ha ha.
- We touched on that a
little bit with Mike Schur
but we'd be happy to dig in a little more.
- Maybe elaborate a little bit on that
and then we can move on
quickly to another one.
If there's more to say-
- What do you think, Rich?
Have you been a good person?
- I don't...
I can't say I have the
ultimate answer to that.
I think that there is wisdom in
philosophical and spiritual
strains of thought
that have survived for thousands of years,
from which you can extract principles
for how to orient your life.
Fundamentally, I think
that being a good person
is intertwined with
that search for purpose
and it always goes back to
finding a way to devote that purpose
in service to other people.
I think fundamentally, being
good is really about service.
- Yeah. Yeah. I heard this
phrase the other day about
being otherish.
Someone was talking about it,
I forget who was saying that.
We're selfish and human
beings are naturally selfish
for a number of reasons, I think.
Because children need to
be selfish to survive.
We needed, as a species,
to be selfish to survive.
I'm gonna feed myself this deer carcass
and make sure that the people in my cave
get the deer carcass.
And then my children get the
piece of the deer carcass.
And there's a,
I sounded like Dwight Schrute just then,
but there's a selfishness in this.
But then as we grow and
mature and progress,
then we can be otherish
instead of selfish.
And how do we be a good person? We just...
When I find myself being good
and I haven't always been good
and I struggle with being good,
it's not like I'm arrived by
any stretch of the imagination.
Ask my wife.
But the idea of trying to be
otherish instead of selfish
helps me in that path.
- I like that term otherish.
I hadn't heard that before.
- I'm gonna steal that.
- [Rainn] Good. You're welcome to it.
- All right. Pick a new one.
I think you're up.
- It's up to me now.
- [Reza] Here we go.
- There's a lot of gabbing.
"What happens after we die?"
This is one of our chief topics
on Metaphysical Milkshake.
I love this topic.
- With Rob Bell in fact that was-
- Oh, is that what you explored with him?
- Two-parter with Rob Bell.
I was obsessed with this
idea that we were asking Rob,
cause he's a Christian who famously
disbelieved in hell, for
lack of a better way of...
It's more complicated than that, but...
And so he got essentially ex-communicated
for those who aren't
familiar with his work.
But he's still a
Christian and very devout.
So I was like, "So
you're gonna meet Jesus?"
"If you get hit by a bus, Rob bell,
what happens between you
getting hit by that bus
and you meeting Jesus?"
"Talk me through it"
- It took two hours.
- Very specifically. Step-by-step.
you're hit by a bus. You
meet Jesus. Like what?
- I think we covered maybe
a second of real time
in two hours.
- We didn't even get
anywhere close to Jesus.
- We didn't even get to
Jesus. We never got there.
- That asshole.
But so what happens after we die?
So I'm writing a book right
now about spirituality,
which is, this is quite an endeavor.
Reza has done it before. It's really hard.
And the I'm taking some
of the biggest topics
in the universe.
I have a chapter on death
and I have a chapter on God
and I have a chapter on religion.
- Just one chapter on God.
(Reza laughs)
- It's killing me.
Literally in that chapter right now its...
I've interviewed Reza about it.
It's killing me. Dude, it really is.
But I'm coming up with some good stuff.
But what happens after
we die I've talked about.
My belief as a Baha'i,
in the Baha'i faith,
we believe that, there's an
analogy that the body is,
it's not just the Baha'i faith,
there's many spiritual traditions,
that the body is a cage.
And that our reality is
the bird within the cage.
And when the cage is
broken, the bird goes free.
And that's not something to be mourned,
the brokenness of the body or of the cage,
it's to be celebrated.
The glorious journey
of the bird flying free
of the material and physical limitations.
But I will say that I recently
had a friend pass away
and this has been a big
year of death for me.
My father passed away about a year ago.
A co-founder of our non-profit in Haiti
died of cancer and then
one of my dear friends
died of cancer-
- [Rich] Sorry to hear that.
- Thanks. ...that recently.
And, you know, it's such a tricky topic,
but there are good ways to die
and there is not so good ways to die.
And in fact, one of our episodes,
sorry, I feel like we're
really plugging the hell
out of this podcast.
- Well, we do ask a
lot of these questions.
- You are here to do that anyway.
Just lean into it.
- We had a death doula on
the show and she was amazing.
And that's like a birth doula.
- Exactly what you think it is.
- She helps you transition towards death
and that can be everything from
where do you keep all
your Facebook passwords?
and also how do you want
your ceremony to be?
how do you want to pass?
- What do you want your
deathbed to look like?
- Yeah, that was the big question.
what want your deathbed...
So in having these discussions,
we talk a lot about death
and this friend of mine who passed away,
he didn't want to look at death.
And I think probably because
he was mostly atheist.
I think that he was like a third.
A bit wondering, but mostly...
And so for him, his journey
towards this inevitability
of death, because he was given
stage four stomach cancer
was like, "I'm gonna fight
cancer, tooth and nail
with every power in my being"
which is great, which is important.
- But fueled by this terror.
- Fueled by terror and kind of like...
And I would talk, I would be
always the voice to talk to him
and say, "David, can we talk
about this a little bit?"
Or I would send him a little
writing from the Dalai Lama
or a Buddhist text or
something about death
and encourage him to get some therapy,
help process the emotions around it.
But we live in the Western culture
in this abject terror of death.
We don't talk about death.
A friend of mine was telling me that,
now in contemporary society, we...
The Victorians never talked about sex,
but talked about death all the time.
In Victorian England,
there were death parties
and there would be
corpse viewings, seances.
And it was just this thing.
And sex was not talked.
And now we just talk about sex.
And everything is like,
reality TV shows are just
literally like, "Hey, these
people are gonna hook up."
Pretty soon we're just gonna
have shows where it's just
people meet and they hook up
and we talked to them having sex.
- I think it's called porn.
- Oh, That's porn.
That's what porn is.
I've never checked it out, I've
been meaning to check that.
- I'll show you some time.
- Is there any on the internet?
- yeah, it's hard to find.
- Okay, thanks. Send me a link.
But this idea that
we are so afraid to talk about death
and it is that one thing
that we all have in common.
Everyone on this podcast
and everyone listening to this podcast.
And if we embrace it
as a continuation of the mystery,
and yes, it's scary,
We can have a very different
relationship to death.
- Yeah, I think it is less about
what happens when we die.
I mean, anybody who answers that question
with any level of certitude is somebody
I'm probably not gonna trust.
(all laughing)
But it is about appreciation of death
and how to bring death
into our daily experience
so that we can appreciate
the richness of life.
Because that is a certitude
and a certain duality
that we need to understand.
Our culture is so whitewashed
of any references to death whatsoever.
And despite our brains intellectually-
- Look at the mass denial happening
in our country right now,
- It's unbelievable.
- 650,000 people dead
in our country in a year and four months.
And we're not talking about it
and they're partying like it's 1999
and there's no one is looking at it.
And so half of the population is going,
I'm sorry to say this, is going...
Like, what the fuck?
And I know that-
- I think it is a reflection
of this very thing, right?
Because we're so afraid of
death and we have so little,
I mean, we don't
connect with it in any way.
Like the minute somebody dies,
they're removed from our line of sight
and we don't have language
for how to talk about it
in a healthy way beyond
the traditional structures
around funerals, et cetera.
And I think intellectually,
we all understand
that we're gonna die,
but I think deep down,
we all think somehow
we're gonna figure out
and run around it, for us personally.
And that creates that low
grade fear that we carry
with us that forces us
to even put it further
out of our vision.
- I think the answer is ultramarathons.
Here's what I would say.
Yeah. I mean, obviously I have
no idea what the hell happens
after we die, but to go back
to what I was saying earlier
about the scientific fact that
we are eternal, right?
That the things that make me what I am,
and I mean like the cells
in my body, the atoms,
the sort of most base structure
of what has created this body is eternal.
Is forever.
Those things don't just go away.
They become something else, right.
Matter and energy is forever.
So that means my cells, my atoms,
they are forever.
They don't just stop being,
they just stop being me.
But I am more than just
this physical body.
Whether you believe in a soul or not,
you believe in consciousness.
A lot of philosophers, a
lot of theologians will say,
"Your consciousness is your soul.
Stop thinking of them
as different things."
That your ability to say, "I am me,"
is you recognizing and communing with
what is your soul.
So if your consciousness is a real thing,
then your consciousness
is also the result of-
- Let me just jump in.
Let me just jump in.
Cause I think it's
important to understand that
scientists don't know
what consciousness is.
This is one of the great mystery. Right?
- And you can't talk about death
without talking about consciousness
and defining what that means.
- You can have brain scans
and you can show some vague
areas in brains that light up
when you look at a piece
of a cherry rhubarb pie
versus a lion in the jungle,
but we don't know what it is.
There's neurons and electrons
and there's there's cells
and there's parts of the brain.
But the idea of consciousness,
loving, laughing, thinking,
pondering memories,
that the unification of all
of these different aspects
of what it is to be alive
and have this quote unquote
internal experience.
I just wanted to say that. For the record.
- And what aspect of that is
individuated versus universal?
This idea of panpsychism,
that everything on some level
is conscious, every
accumulation of matter.
And that there is bees
in the hive that we share
some kind of consciousness God head.
- I actually believe that, but fine,
if you don't believe that
you could still follow what I'm saying.
And yes, Rainn is absolutely right.
Whatever consciousness
is, And we don't know,
is involved in our biological processes.
Right. So I guess what
I'm saying is when I die,
all the things that
make up my material self
continue forever. That's science.
The matter continues forever.
The energy continues forever.
Well, if my consciousness
is, in some ways,
the sum of my matter and my energy,
then who's to say my consciousness
doesn't continue forever
in some way, shape or form.
Do you know what I mean?
When, when people ask me,
"Do you believe in life after death?"
That to me is life after death.
That the thing that makes me me
continues in some way.
My consciousness doesn't
disappear because my consciousness
is the result of matter
and energy and matter,
and energy doesn't disappear.
- And that's very Sufi.
- Right.
So the answer is, "I don't know,"
but that's my prevailing theory.
- There's a great metaphor
in the Baha'i writings
that I've talk about
in my chapter on death,
which is, it's pretty simple.
It's kind of like the
bird in the cage one.
It's a little bit, might call it simple,
but its also profound.
And that is that when
we're a baby in the womb,
we're growing what we need
for this physical world.
So we're in floating and
in this kind of stasis,
growing our bones, our
eyelashes, our ears and lips
and eyebrows and elbows and everything
that we're gonna need.
The baby has no idea
why it's growing elbows.
If you ask the baby, interview the baby,
"What's up with elbows?
Baby's like, "I have no idea.
I'm sitting in this
amniotic sac. I'm fine.
I'm connected with my mother.
It's all, it's all good.
Elbows? I don't need elbows."
But then there's this very scary event of
going through the birth canal
and like, "Oh, shit. this whole experience
is coming to an end.
This is terrifying.
There's blood and there's
pain. There's discomfort."
But what an incredible
world we get born into.
You get to you get to
see Picasso paintings
and you get to have parties
and you get to fall in love
and there's all kinds of
new experiences await you.
Well, the same thing happens.
So I don't know what happens when we die,
but I think metaphorically speaking,
we are, like the death doula might say,
we are being born into a new experience.
And what we're growing in this world
are not physical arms and legs.
We're growing spiritual
arms and legs and elbows.
We're growing patience
and kindness and humility
and compassion and love and honesty.
And these qualities that are,
quote unquote higher qualities,
but qualities of light,
those are what we take
with us when we're plunged
through that painful,
difficult, bloody, difficult,
painful birth canal of death
into this other reality.
- I love that.
- There's also something
beautiful about wonder
and not knowing the answer
that I think gives our
lives a level of richness.
If we could know everything,
is that something that we should aspire to
and/ or is it even possible
to know everything?
Is it possible to answer
that question with certitude,
What happens after death?
And if we could answer it, should we?
- Pass that bowl.
- [Rich] I don't know.
- Good point.
- All right. Let's see. Let's see.
Next up.
- Do we have to do all these questions?
- No. (laughs)
- "What is the nature of consciousness?"
- Wow, we just did that.
Wow, we're ahead. We're ahead on time.
- "Do we have a soul? What is it to you?"
I Kind of feel like...
- You were talking about
consciousness as a soul.
- We just did that.
I mean, I think the
consciousness, soul, death thing,
that's all one and the same.
Maybe we will get through all these.
- We're gonna knock all
these out. Look at that.
- Soul is just a word.
Its just a word and we...
Ooh. What does it mean to be human? Ooh.
Damn.
- That's good.
- Do you have a chapter
on that one in your book?
- Not yet. (laughs)
- Okay.
- Here's another one.
Can I be on your podcast?
Rich! What? Come on.
Human. Do you even know?
- I'm not sure.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
- What is it about being human
and how being human distinguishes us
from the rest of the animal kingdom,
the Fila out there,
that we have a sense of self-awareness,
that we have this yearning
towards spirituality,
that we have a level of consciousness
that allows us to ponder the
nature of consciousness itself?
Is this just the evolution
in brain capacity
or is it something
qualitatively different?
- Even pondering mortality?
Maybe part of, I once said
that to my friend, I was like.
He's an atheist, describing
us as essentially apes
with bigger brains.
I'm like, "Well, we're very different
because we get to ponder our mortality
and animals don't ponder their mortality."
He's like, "Oh, that's preposterous,"
but it's true.
- But is that a brain volume thing
or is that something different altogether?
- I think it's different altogether,
but I think one of the
things that makes us human
is that we get to have
this bowl of questions
and we get to have this
discussion about these questions,
That's one thing.
- The problem with the
brain argument about
what does it mean to be human,
their our brains are just different,
is that, well, then that means eventually,
we're gonna be able to
replicate that brain.
Eventually we'll be able to
put the same neural processes
that make me think about
my mortality into a robot.
And so now the robot is
thinking about its mortality,
is the robot human now?
- I'd watch that movie.
- That doesn't necessarily
lead to consciousness.
- That's right. Pondering death.
I mean, we know that
rhesus monkey and elephants
visit graves, they think about
their fellow monkeys and
fellow elephants that have died
a long time ago.
- We assume that's what they're doing
because their behaviors
seem to allude to that
but We don't know what thinking.
- Are we anthropomorphizing it?.
- Well, I mean, especially with elephants,
there's no reason for them,
years later to revisit
burial sites and yet they do.
- They seem to be
mourning. Picking up bones.
- So we see behavior.
So that's all we can do
is theorize based on
their behavior, I guess.
The reason that I was stumped
by this question is that I'm
wary of the brain argument.
People ask, going back to
what we had said before,
Oh, that spirituality
resides in the brain.
It's part of our cognitive processes
so it must be there for a reason
and you should probably think about that.
The question then is, "Oh, okay.
Well then if I figure that out,
it's bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop.
and then I do bloop, bloop,
bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop
into a robot.
Will the robot believe in God? Yeah.
Yes, it will.
So what does that mean about
what is unique about my brain?
I don't know.
When you were talking about panpsychism
and I said, "Yeah, that's me.
That's actually what I believe."
I think that's what I mean.
It's that it's hard for
me to differentiate myself
all that much from the rest of existence,
simply because my brain's
a little bit different.
Do you know what I mean?
I accept that my brain is
different and I rejoice in that,
but it's hard for me to
feel too Supreme about it,
knowing that whatever my brain is
could possibly be replicated.
- I think what you're getting at, Reza is
there is a Western Christian
philosophical Supremeism
that is really a little bit revolting.
Which is kind of like,
"We are superior to the animals
and therefore we care take the animals
or we have dominion over the animals,
We have dominion over the
earth and we're arrived
and we have the holy spirit in us.
And there's this, and I'm
doing that fakey voice accent
because there is that.
- It filters into
non-religious thinking as well.
You don't have to be
religious to think that way.
- I think, on top of that,
there is that hubris extends
to this notion that we are
capable of understanding everything.
It's just a matter of refining our science
and over time figuring
all of these things out.
- In 57 years, we'll have consciousness
completely figure out.
- Exactly, I just don't
see that being possible.
In the same way that a beetle
is never gonna understand
the human language.
The brain capacity of that organism just
prevents it from
understanding certain things
that are obvious to us. Right?
So how much, and so the hubris
plays into this idea that
we are supremely evolved,
that there is nothing,
there is no truth that alludes
our capacity to understand
and I just think that's preposterous.
- Yeah. Especially with our
limited senses that we have,
Just have these five senses.
- And they're not all that good
compared the rest of the animal kingdom.
- (all) Yeah.
- Hi, Rich. (grunts)
All right. We have time
for like one more of these.
- [Reza] Yeah, one more.
Make it a good one.
- Come on. I'm going hot pink.
"Are all religions
fundamentally the same?"
- We covered that a little bit.
From a Baha'i's standpoint, but
also Reza's standpoint then.
- I would just say, just be,
and this is kind of a big deal
over the last 30, 40 years
in religious studies.
Cause a big part of the early 20th century
of religious studies was all about
religions are fundamentally all
saying the exact same thing,
but using different languages
and I agree with that.
And then sometime around the
sixties and the seventies,
there was a backlash to that
because people were saying
"But you're not taking
those differences seriously enough."
Right. That there's a reason
why Christianity is different
than Islam and Islam is
different than Judaism
and Judaism is different than
Baha'i et cetera, et cetera.
And that we shouldn't wash
away those differences
by simply saying, "Well,
they're all pretty much
saying the same thing."
They are all pretty much
saying the same thing.
That's actually true.
But let's not devalue those
differences is all I will say.
- Yeah. Well put.
- Sure. Let's get with that.
- One or two more of these.
Oh, I love this one.
Are we addicted to everything?
- Boom.
- That's a title of one
of our episodes episodes.
- You stole it from one of our episodes.
- I did.
- Dr Gabor Maté.
- It hasn't gone up yet though.
- It has not gone up.
- I had Gabor on my show.
And this is a subject that-
- Did he blow you away the
way that he blew me away?
because I was...
- Did he flip it on you?
- Oh, he flipped it on me so quickly.
- I'm like, "Please flip it on me.
I am gonna take advantage, yes."
- He broke Reza down
- I was so done and I was like
- I was in tears.
I mean, Rainn has talked about,
he's had some addiction issues
and he's been very open about it.
And I was like, "Listen,
I'm not an addict.
I've never been addicted.
I mean, sure. I'd take
part in various vices,
but I'm not addicted to anything."
And Rainn, in the middle of the podcast,
just as a joke was like,
"Well, you're a workaholic."
And I was like, "Well,
what does that even mean?
A workaholic."
And then Dr. Gabor Maté
(all chatter)
- "You are the children of
immigrants and your father
and your meaning to your
parents is so important
and you have come to America
and what you make of yourself
is how you get to
complete your self-esteem.
And it's your family and it's
how you break your family down
and what they look to you.
And you are nothing
without your successes."
- Cause I was like, "I
have six jobs. So what?
That's awesome. That makes me great."
"Why is that a bad thing?"
- I worked 16 hours a day.
And Gabor Maté theory
is that all addiction
stems from trauma and I was like, "What?
Not trauma. What trauma?"
This dude just broke me down.
And now I realize, "Oh,
shit. I am a workaholic.
I have an addiction."
- That comes from some trauma.
- Comes from the trauma of-
- you're a first-generation immigrant.
- Refugee, leaving everything behind.
Coming to America with nothing
and starting all over again.
- In Oklahoma, right?
- Did you feel the pull
to defend your parents?
- Oh, totally.
Yeah, totally.
And now I was defending myself.
- It was really profound in
that my discussion with him.
I wanna hear what he said to you, Rich.
I'll listen to that podcast specifically,
but I said, "Me, I'm so
probably addicted to
pretty much anything one
can become addicted to."
I joked, I'm having my
green here and I was like,
"It's the one addiction I allow myself."
I don't even have like hard...
I quit coffee cause it was too hardcore
but I said, "the weird thing is that,
and everyone in my family is addicted,
My dad wasn't addicted to anything."
who passed away this last year
and Gabor Maté was like,
"Well, what did your father die from?"
And I was like, "Well, he
died of heart disease."
"What kind of heart disease?"
"Well, his arteries
were completely clogged
and they tried to do a quadruple bypass
and they couldn't get in.
It was just too clogged and backed up.
And his aorta wasn't even working."
He's like, "Heart disease
come from trauma."
"Heart diseases is own kind of addiction.
It's a trauma response.
They've proven heart disease
as a trauma response."
Holy shit. That really blew my mind
cause my dad had this
incredibly traumatic childhood,
but he never did drugs, he never drank,
He never fucked around.
He didn't do any of that stuff.
And I was like, "Why is he super human?"
And yet he died at 78
with his entire chest
just clogged with trans fats, I guess.
That really put up perspective.
There's a heartbreak in
that physical condition.
- He has quite the gift of
just lasering in on that thing
that you're not even
aware was such a big piece
of your behavior.
- what did he get on you?
- Well, for me. It's
like, my parents love me.
They took care of all my
needs. They love each other.
They're still together.
I'm long-time sober. I've been
in recovery for a long time.
And of course over the years people go,
"Why do you think you're an alcoholic?"
and one of the things
you learn in 12 step is
that's not really a fruitful
kind of thought experiment
because it doesn't really provide you
with the tools to live now.
So you focus on the solution
and your character defects,
et cetera, and working the steps.
So I hadn't spent a lot of
time trying to understand
what might have led me down this path,
but I was certain that it
had nothing to do with family
history because I didn't
grow up with any alcoholism
in the family.
I don't know anybody in my
extended family that had it.
I didn't suffer any trauma growing up
that you would point to
and say, "Poor Rich."
He had a, you know, typical kid stuff,
bullying and the like.
But nothing that I could
point a finger at my parents
and say, "My affliction is attributable
in some part to this."
But what he did was
helped me understand that,
and I'm very protective of my parents
because they blame themselves
and I'm constantly saying,
"It's not your fault,"
but I did grow up in a very achievement,
education-oriented household where love
corresponded to how well
you were doing in school
or what you were achieving.
My achievements were all
this quest to seek approval
and acceptance and love on some level.
Not in a really pernicious way,
but definitely in a way that was real.
And so he helped me understand that.
And I was like, No, I
don't want to blame."
He's like, "It's not about
your parents being bad people.
They're good people. They
did their best or whatever,"
but just recognizing that truth, I think
has been helpful to me.
And yet at the same time,
and I'm interested in
what you guys think about this,
I feel that that Gabor is sort of a hammer
in search of a nail
and I think addiction really
is a little bit more complex
than just saying,
I think childhood trauma
is a big piece in that,
but I think it's reductive to
say, "It's because of this.
And if you heal this,
you will no longer have
your addiction problem."
I don't think that it works that way.
- I think I agree with that
and it is very complicated
and he, and we're
obviously simplifying what
Gabor would say about stuff,
But I do think that there is...
I would ask the question
a little bit differently.
Instead of, "Are we
addicted to everything?"
My question would be, "Why
are we addicted to things?"
Why do all of us find something that
we have addictive behavior towards?
And if his theory is that
because underneath it somewhere,
somewhere underneath it there's trauma.
- Well, I think even going
further beneath that,
there's a spirituality to all of it,
because addiction is rooted
in the search for answers
or the search for comfort or
making sense of the world,
or trying to understand how
you belong to this thing.
- One thing that he
said that I thought was,
that I hadn't heard before,
cause you know, addiction is a disease
and addiction is this and is this.
And his argument was that
addiction is the symptom to a problem.
So maybe the problem isn't trauma,
I think you're absolutely right
that he will always bring
it back to trauma somehow.
- and Johann Hari will always
bring it back to connection.
I don't know if you read
his book, Lost Connection,
that's his vein-
- Or The spiritual disconnection,
- [Rainn] Spiritual malady.
- Whatever the case may be.
But there is something to
be said about thinking of
addiction as a symptom.
Now what is it a symptom of?
That's fine. There's
different things to it.
And I think that was
kind of eyeopening to me
to find the thing that you feel
like you can't live without
and then ask why. Right?
- Well, the drug or the behavior
is the solution to the problem.
It's not the problem.
- Well, to pull the
camera back a little bit.
There's 7 billion people on the planet.
Are we addicted to everything?
And the answer is yes.
And I agree with Gabor Maté in this sense
and the other author,
I'm not familiar with,
you're talking about connection.
I would agree with that as well.
in terms of looking,
if you're an alien looking down
at humanity on this planet,
you'll be like, yes, there's a trauma.
And there's a trauma which
is 10,000 years of wars
and 10,000 years of starvation
and 10,000 years of droughts
and how difficult it is to survive.
So we want stuff and comfort.
And we want security.
And so what is that?
That means more stuff and
more toys and more things
and nicer things and softer beds
and more choices in mattress foams,
and smartphones that can
do everything for us.
We'll never get lost again.
We'll never experience
the pain of being lost
because we have Ways on our phones.
And we'll never be bored again
because we have instant
distraction with 147 games
on our phones.
And so humanity, 7 billion of us,
is a traumatized species on a planet,
but we keep gonna the
wrong, just like an addict.
We keep gonna the wrong
well to soothe ourselves.
We instead of, just like an
addict will go to the gin
to soothe themselves cause
that worked for a couple years
out of college.
It worked quite effectively
until it didn't work anymore.
But humanity keeps
gonna the well of stuff.
So it's status and stuff
and safety and comfort
instead of connection.
And instead of this inevitable
spiritual transformation that will happen,
whether a billion people need to die of
climate change related
catastrophe along the way
for us to do it but in
some way, shape or form,
we will evolve to a higher
level of connectivity
and not keep going to oil and materialism
and consumerism to soothe of human wound.
- But short of a revolution
of consciousness,
can we get there?
Because I think it is true that
we are addicted to everything.
I used to think of addiction
just in terms of drugs,
alcohol, gambling, sex,
the typical laundry list.
But really the more time
I've spent in recovery,
I am utterly convinced that
addiction lives on this
incredibly broad spectrum.
And it can be your
capacity for just being in unhealthy
relationships all the time,
or always seeking out the wrong partner
all the way to our smartphones, of course,
but it's all reinforced by this culture
that is shoving down our
throats this message that
the happiness that we seek
and the spiritual union,
the yearning that we
all share can be sated
through consumption and accumulation.
And until we have a reformation
of our social and cultural priorities,
can that ever truly change,
or do we just delve
deeper into this abyss?
- That may be what climate
change is giving us.
- Maybe.
- I hope. Yeah.
- But I mean, it will be horrific if the
scientific predictions are correct,
and we go to three degrees,
four degrees Celsius change,
it will be incredibly dire.
And I don't want to undersell that,
but it may force a global reckoning about
how we are in harmony with each other
and in harmony with our planet
and in harmony with
materialism slash consumerism.
- It is providing us with
this opportunity. Yeah.
- You know, we joke a
lot about how, "Oh, man,
what we really need is an alien invasion.
If we only had an alien invasion
then we'd all unite together."
We're having alien invasion,
the planet's on fire.
It's here.
- We've never been more
divided ann our facility
for healthy, productive
communication has been so eroded.
It's insane.
And I think if we were invaded
by aliens, there would be,
half the population saying it was a hoax
and the other populate, you know...
Can we ever truly agree on a
shared version of reality anymore?
I don't know.
We're running out of time here,
but we can't end on this.
(all chattering)
- I know. That got so
doom and gloom at the end.
Oh my goodness.
- What are we gonna do?
We need a U-turn here.
- All right. Here's one for you.
- Let's go back a page
and I will say that,
here, give me those cards again.
The ones...
I think that
these questions,
how to be a good person?
How can we? oh, there's more over here.
What is the nature of consciousness?
What does it mean to be human?
You know, what it means to be human
is to have these discussions
about these questions,
to question our lives, to
try and be a better person,
to ponder what happens after we die.
And what do people misunderstand
about spirituality?
I mean, this is kind of
the thesis of my book,
is that we need a spiritual revolution
to transform not only
on an individual level,
but on a societal level.
And we can do it.
And I really believe, even
just watching the Olympics
and I know it's corny and
NBC is really good at like,
"She was up at 4:00 AM every
morning before anyone else got
awake and doing laps in the pool
and her grandmother drove her
and she could only afford
Cheetos to eat for breakfast.
And now she's the fastest
200 meter butterfly swimmer
in the world."
And you get all invested in that.
I'm just a sucker for it,
but the teamwork, the comradery
of these swimming teams,
like holding each other and
sobbing in each other's arms
and how hard they've worked,
the ingenuity, the strength.
I believe in us.
I mean, this is ultimately
what it comes down to.
Its like, I believe in
humanity, I really do.
The bottom of my heart, I
believe that we have the ability
to connect, to heal and to use tools from
the various spiritual
traditions to elevate.
The world is in this rapid,
what is it, disintegration
that's happening right now.
We've talked about that, climate change
and the political disunity,
but we're also in a place of integration
and there have been
tremendous strides forward.
Look at the strides forward
with the conversations
around race in this country.
No, we have not healed
racism. It's not over.
Long way to go,
but We really are at a different place
than we were two years ago.
- We're reckoning with
it in a way we weren't.
- Yeah. And the same
with the me too movement
and women in the workplace.
And especially, we feel this in Hollywood
and I'm sure it's in
other businesses as well,
but Hollywood was such a
sexist and corrupt business.
And now there's a reckoning there as well.
And so there are forces of integration.
There are forces of that
are moving us forward.
And I believe that
the human beauty, ingenuity, fortitude
and determination we see in the Olympics
can be put on to 7 billion
of us sharing this planet.
- And then I'll just say-
- You did it. you turned it around.
- How about that.
- Hand the Olympic baton.
(Rainn yelling)
I can't do this race cause I smoke pot.
- And you eat donuts.
- I eat donuts.
I think that
when you narrow your vision
to our present moment,
then it's impossible to be optimistic.
It's impossible to think anything other
than we are all screwed. It's over.
Try to broaden that
view just for a minute.
Just open up your vision for a second.
Look at this present moment as though
it is an instant in a gigantic timeline.
I think about the fact that something that
one of our guests, Malcolm
Gladwell brought up,
there was a battle in World War 1.
One battle in which 1 million
people died in one battle.
In one battle, okay?
We are as far away from
that experience today
as we are from mapping
consciousness, right?
So broaden your viewpoint a little bit
and it'll infect you with
a little bit more optimism.
And then the only other
thing that I can say-
- And let me add to that,
think about this American civil war.
Think about the fact what did
people think about in 1867
- It's 150 Years ago, that
was not that long ago.
- And when 2 million people
were dead on battlefields
and bloods soaked battlefields,
and the whole country was
at each other's throats,
People say, "Oh, it's never been as bad
in the United States as it is now."
What about the civil war?
What about millions and millions dead?
And it probably seemed like
there wasn't a way out.
I just want to support your thesis.
- The only other thing that I will say is
it's also very easy to listen
to all these incredibly
loud voices.
Voices of radicalism and extremism,
whether they be religious or political
or whatever the case may be,
because those loud voices
are what get the attention.
They're the ones that come up on top,
but always remember that
any kind of fundamentalism,
whether it's religious fundamentalism
or political fundamentalism,
ethnic, racial,
whatever the case may
be, is by definition,
a reactionary phenomenon.
The voices of extremism that you hear
are not independent phenomena.
They are a reaction to what
is independent phenomena.
So when you hear someone's screaming
about racism or political
extremism or religious fanaticism,
understand that what that
is a reaction to progress
and secularization and pluralism,
and a diversity.
It's pluralism, progress, diversity.
Those are the things. That's the stream.
What you are hearing is
the response to the stream.
- So focusing on the stream.
- Don't freak out. Focus on the stream.
- Right.
And no progress occurs
without that resistance
or that friction. Right?
So the loud voices are the friction,
but they're really the
dying voices in the night
as culture progress's.
- Don't confuse it.
Just because it's the
loudest doesn't mean-
- Yeah. There were those same loud voices
in the civil rights era
and the same loud voices
defending our role
in the Vietnam war.
The same thing was happening then.
- Put your head down and progress.
- Well, I feel like this
was the everything bagel
of Metaphysical Milkshakes.
(all laugh)
We put it in the Vitamax
and I don't know how it's gonna taste.
But we did it.
How do you feel? it was
good. It was cool, right?
- This is what we do.
its what we live for.
I dig it. I love the show,
Metaphysical Milkshake
available, wherever you
listen to fine podcasts,
and you guys are easy
to find on the internet.
Other than that, anything coming up
or anything you want to point
people towards? More episodes?
Are you doing this like in seasons
or are you just gonna be putting them up?
- We don't really know. They're like...
- They just keep telling us.
- They are like, we need
more episodes. Okay.
- Who's they?
- The podcast gods.
- Yeah. I mean, we enjoy it.
I think we promised that we would do,
I think maybe 40 or 45 of them a year,
which seems insane,
but we'll just keep doing
it as long as it's fun.
I think the second it's not fun.
Both of us will look at
each other and be like,
you know what.
- We'll Throw in the towel.
And they'll live on.
The conversations will live on.
But yeah, it's, it's a blast.
I mean, I love having
elevated conversations
and what a treat to share this with Reza
and you're doing the same thing over here
and a big admirer of your podcast
and thanks for having us on.
- Thanks you guys.
And when those books are ripe and ready,
come back and share with
me about them, please.
- Cool. Alright.
- Peace.
- plants. Namaste.
(calm lo-fi music)